so I've taken some screenshots of the
Khan Academy exercise interpreting rate
of change for exponential models in
terms of change maybe they're going to
change the title that seems a little bit
too long but anyway let's let's actually
just tackle these together so the first
day of spring an entire field of
flowering trees blossoms the population
of locusts consuming these flowers
rapidly increases as the trees blossom
the relationship between the elapsed
time T in days since the beginning of
spring and the total number of locusts L
of T so the number of locust is going to
be a function of the number of days that
have elapsed since the beginning of
spring is modeled by the following
function so locusts as a function of
time it's going to be 750 times 1.85 to
the teeth power complete the following
sentence about the daily rate of change
of the locust population every day the
locust population well every day think
about what's going to happen I'll draw a
little table just to make it hopefully a
little bit clearer so let me draw a
little bit of a table so we'll put T and
LF t so when T is 0 so when 0 days have
elapsed well there's going to be 1 point
8 5 to the 0th power this is going to be
1 so you're going to have 750 locusts
right from the get-go
then when T equals 1 what's going to
happen well then this is going to be 750
times 1 point 8 5 to the first power so
it's going to be times 1 point 8 5 when
T is equal to 2 what cell of T it's
going to be 750 times 1 point 8 5
squared well that's the same thing as 1
point 8 5 times 1 point 8 5 so notice
and this is just comes out of this being
an exponential function every day you
have one point eight five times as many
as you had the day before one point
eight five we essentially take what we
had the day before we multiply by one
point eight five and since one point
eight five is larger than one this
going to grow the number of locusts we
have so this is going to grow
I'm actually not using I'm not on the
website right now so that's why I
normally there would be a drop down here
so I'm going to grow by a factor of well
I'm going to grow by a factor of one
point eight five every day let's do
another one of these all right so this
one tells us that Veera is an ecologist
who studies the rate of change in the
bear population of Siberia over time the
relationship between the elapsed time T
in years since viewer began studying the
population and the total number of bears
and of T is modeled by the following
function alright fair enough it's a
little got a little exponential thing
going on complete the following sentence
about the yearly rate of change of the
bear population well just think about
every year that passes T is in years now
every year that passed is going to be
2/3 times the year before I can do that
same table that I just did just to make
that clear so let me do that
whoops me let me make this clear so
table so this is T and this is n of T
when T is 0 n of T you're going to have
2187 bears so that's the first year that
you began studying that population 0
years since this V R began setting the
population the first year is going to be
2187 times 2/3 to the first power so
times 2/3 the second year is going to be
2187 times 2/3 to the second power so
there's just 2/3 times 2/3 so each
successive year you're going to have 2/3
is the bear population of the year
before you're multiplying the year
before by 2/3 so every year the bear
population shrinks shrinks by a factor
of by a factor of 2/3 I let's do one
more of these so they tell us that Akiba
started studying how the number of
branches on his tree change over time
all right the relationship between the
elapsed time T in years since the kiba
study started studying history and the
total number of its branches n ft is
modeled by the following function
complete the following sentence about
the yearly percent change in the number
of branches every year blank % of
branches are added or subtracted from
the total number of branches
well I'll draw them another table
although you might get used to just
being able to look at this and say well
look each year you're going to have 1.75
times the number of branches you had the
year before and so we have 1.75 times
the number of branches the year before
you have grown by 75% and I'll make a
little bit clearer so 75% of Brett every
year 75% of branches are added to the
total number of branches and I'll just
draw that table again like I've done in
the last two examples to make that
hopefully clear ok ok so this is T and
this is n of T so T equals 0 you have 42
branches T equals 1 it's going to be 42
times 1.75 times one point seven five
when T equals two is going to be 42
times one point seven five squared 42
times one point seven five times one
point seven five so every year you are
multiplying times one point seven five
so times one point seven five something
funky is happening with my pen right
over there but if you're multiplying by
one point 75 if you're growing by a
factor of one point seventy five this is
the same thing as adding 75 percent it's
again you are adding 75 percent think
about it this way if I if you just grew
by a factor of one then you're not
adding anything you're staying constant
if you grow by 10 percent then you're
going to be 1.1 times as large if you
grow by 200 percent then you're going to
be 2 times as large so this right over
here this right over here is is is going
or if you let me be clear careful when I
just said I think I just mistake that if
you grow by 200% you're going to be
three times as large as you were before
one is constant and then another 200%
would be another twofold so that make
you three times as large don't want to
confuse the eye my brain recognize that
I said something weird right at that end
all right hopefully you enjoyed that